hello guys this is Ryan the right here
and my name is dana revelry taylor
Bradley is here again
I brought Taylor here to check out
something special on I think it was
Christmas I announced that anyone who
has a sketch or a short film that is a
subscriber to this channel they can go
ahead and submit a short film or sketch
only if it's a short film or sketch and
I'll review it and I'll be honest about
how I feel about it sorry if I don't
like it but you're gonna get my honest
opinion I brought Taylor here Taylor has
a web series I just launched recently
italiano Americana you gotta watch it
it's a fun series and I was like she's
the perfect person to start this off
with since she's working on a web series
right now this is a short horror film
from Joseph Escobedo well uh he said I
love you Ryan please excuse my acting in
the beginning please I know it's
horrible but believe my first short film
oh okay cool
I'm excited I wish I knew how old these
people were that way I'm not like if
he's like 12 you're gonna judge the
material differently then it for like
2014 uh tragic I said you just judge it
honestly and I think that's really
helpful for anyone at any age all right
we might rip you apart good
- great name yeah please let me find a
babysitter for Josh for Friday night so
I could please hang out with my friends
he's leaving for the Marines in a week
please this is the only time I've a
chance dang elephant before leaves okay
thank you I will find a babysitter and
please when are you guys gonna come home
anyway okay well please come back soon
okay please please come back please I
love you should have called that doesn't
product placement yeah Apple
okay well that's we know how old he is
that's the intense look that's him and
he said please forgive my act you know
yuning is a cool shot that was it that
was a cool shot give you that map good
camera I like the shutter speed mm-hmm
please phone call hey what's up dude hey
um you don't mind me asking I might need
a little favor from you I want to visit
my cousin for relief suffer the Marines
upon Friday and I need a babysitter
babysit Josh do you mind if you can
babysit for me - thanks dude you're the
best that's why you're the best friend
dude I love you dude you're the best
I owe you yes I owe you I did
I'll see I'm sorry I kind of wish he
actually made phone calls yeah um right
yeah I know this is you acting you see
your horrible you're not horrible like
some of your line reading not badly I
don't know if it was completely scripted
though or not it seemed a little bit
yeah creepy creepy shut the Lighting's
cool it's consistent for the most part
yeah there's a lot of dead air though
you mean too harsh cool shots you're
gonna be a good cinematographer man you
got some cool the camera we're here yeah
okay
so you know if you know the rules right
instead of coming so remember to behave
because every time I give you babysitter
you always mess it up in the nail and
run away and I never get that fun so
please please please can you please
behave okay okay fine but I always
behave okay I'm gonna go now you're good
Victor's coming I'll see you later
tonight all right
oh yeah bye
the background noise on that microphone
man mm-hmm it's a good microphone though
it's a good Michael I bet I'd rather it
be too loud than not be able to hear it
the setting is causing that fuzzy I
thought it'd be black like how
comfortable he's making himself its
babysitters yeah free filly walks over
there it seems like they already know
each other I think so because he's his
brothers front my name is Maxwell
Thompson no no look you know I don't
want to do anything okay
I just want to do my own thing and you
don't have to babysit me okay I I'm 13
years old I agree you're 13
yes you don't want to babysit yes
who's that the twitch yeah get a rapey
vibe hey you supposed to yeah gonna rape
him take that great soft bunny good
[Music]
the babies that are crying yeah yeah he
lost the game that's in front of them
was replaced nice it's good thing that
lights their lighteth riffin it's kind
of a creepy vibe though the light he
learned that camera angle
[Music]
[Music]
I'm just looking at the great person
moon
[Music]
[Music]
surely doubting that
[Music]
what the [ __ ] going on it seems like
the tension is like really high because
of the music but nothing's really
happened yet except that he cried and
now he's drinking a lot of lemonade he's
tryna get ahold of his brother yeah
[Music]
can't see anything
I know he fell it was like there's the
light on the dust really yeah now it's
flipped
[Music]
what are you doing out here you you
killed him I'm sorry to say this I'm
gonna have to kill you
[Music]
good thing new tools ready how is he
still alive after that he's had like a
thousand time get a third weapon kids
never gonna be the same
where's he crime cuz it just killed
someone and his brother brothers dad
ethic
why would his brother be good I don't
know he said you killed him and he said
now I'm gonna have to kill you too
[Music]
okay time for an honest review start off
with positives okay there's some good
camera angles in there yes is there
gonna be a really good center fit
cinematographer yeah for the most part
like there are some really cool shots in
there yeah
tension was mysteriously felt even
though I wasn't sure what the hell was
going on which is also props to the
music yeah it's good score impose err
yeah creepy music is you didn't just
download some [ __ ] like I do
royalty free I know a composer now so
the next [ __ ] just I have a complete
haha well I will say though is as far as
a storytelling goes I can tell us that
thing would like try to do as much as
possible without doing much dialogue and
that's cool um if you attempt that
however a lot of this just didn't make
sense in my opinion like why was the
babysitter crying who did the babysitter
exactly kill was there anything to
establish that the brother was killed
other than the fact that he wasn't
picking up his phone right you know
because we knew he was already gonna be
out yeah and it seemed like there were a
couple jumps I do appreciate the fact
that you already know from the get-go to
show not tell that's one of the hardest
things I feel like that new movie the
short movie makers learn because you
want to be able to tell so much because
you don't want your audience to be
confused but you kind of jumped on the
opposite spectrum
yeah and you didn't tell us enough and
so I felt like I was a little bit lost
through most of it I think that there
was a couple moments a really great
tension though when he's out on the
patio trying to call his brother and the
guy pops out that freaked me out for a
minute like I was like yeah crap like
what's gonna happen but I did not
understand the weight of that situation
or of that moment because he had already
been crying and then I didn't understand
the lemonade I think wait was like
lemonade but it was a freaking long shot
there's a lot of takes of him just I
know there was there was a long shot at
that and so I thought that it was gonna
hold more weight like I was like is he
an alien like does he need to drink a
whole lot in order to be your mind goes
racing races well yeah I try to fill in
any blanks when you watch films don't
you try to like fill in any of the
blanks you're like oh
it's because of this or I wonder if it's
because of this fill in blanks there's
got to be a sex joke fill in shooting
blanks give back to me on that okay I
did enjoy it it didn't feel like it was
too long which was good I was never like
oh my god is this over yet however you
said this is your first short film
that's really good for a first short
film yes like way better than what I've
done in my first like few short films so
fantastic job in terms of that like your
camera angles are good the biggest issue
I see even that I struggle with the most
that like any one encounters I noticed
for amateur filmmaking is the sound
sound design is really hard it's it's so
important like I didn't realize just how
valuable a sound design person is until
I realized I really need one because
anytime there's a cut or sounds off
that's what pulls people out the most
because it feels the most amateurs at
that point and the whole the whole goal
is to yes amateur filmmaking but you
want to try to look like professional
you know right and so I would suggest
sound design finding a sound design guy
fortunately just found one and you said
your acting was horrible and it wasn't
horrible like you're the dude in the
beginning right like it wasn't horrible
if there's one criticism I give in the
performance it would actually be the the
bad guy the BabyCenter yeah I actually
really liked the kid the kid was cool
yeah he was believable he was likable I
thought he was gonna be the evil one at
first he was appropriately weird for a
13 year old kid but the thing that kind
of threw me off is that you also set it
up for him to kind of be the bad guy
when you're like you keep scaring off
all the babysitters
but then there's nothing that he really
did that would have scared off a
babysitter like he was very well
tempered like he just said I'm 13 I
don't really need a babysitter he wasn't
mean to him or anything so I would have
liked to see some some connection there
because you said it and I don't think
that you know any of the lines should be
wasted and I think I feel like if you're
gonna go with violent death go all out
yeah there should have been blood and
guts this kitchen having covered in
brains and whatever just everything and
then he should have like ripped off his
penis and beat him more in the head
with the penis and he should have the
kid should have liked taking off his
pants and just shat on his chest and
then then peed on top of it to create an
even more disgusting scent and then
afterwards just on his corpse that would
have been a good babysitter course I
guess go for it tell you
Joseph Escobedo thanks for being the
first one to submit a short film there's
more to come people anyway guys listen
if more to come fill in the blanks
you've come to fill in the blanks we're
honest well almost there hey you're
almost there if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe today by
clicking this button that I placed in
front of me Taylor Bradley you can
follow her on Instagram
Taylor Bradley 91 and on her youtube
channel they have launched Italiano
Americana a comedy web series about two
Italians in America almost yeah it's
100% [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] like this the
whole time it stars a hot girl guy one
day King the hot girl he'll want to show
one day come on the channel cuz she's
hot yeah that's the rule part of the
criteria come on the real rejects oh sit
down gotta be hot Taylor hot okay
it's how it works that's my compliment
for the day thanks enjoy it I am